et notre invité politique ce matin c'est
donc alexis corbière bonjour je merci
beaucoup d'être avec vous invitez
d'écouter la france insoumise et la
seine-saint-denis on est ensemble
pendant 20 minutes pour une interview en
partenariat avec la presse quotidienne
régionale représenté par jefferson des
sports de sud-ouest bonjour de faire ça
bonjour orione bonjour lexique en bière
jours et on commence avec cette
actualité alexis corbière et l'australie
qui a donc rompu brutalement son contrat
avec la france pour la construction de
sous marins est ce que vous dénoncez un
coup poignarde les australiens des
américains l'expression coup de poignard
et celle de jean yves le drian
effectivement est la vôtre celui-ci ne
fait je vous dirais là c'est une formule
choc 56 milliards d'euros c'est un
contrat très important qui effectivement
on va avoir des dégâts je pense
notamment à cherbourg pour les salariés
navale groupe iii qui était le groupe
qui devait réaliser certains de ces
travaux
on verra mais de montrer à écouter quand
vous avez un contrat de 56 milliards qui
vous passent sous le nez si ça n'a
aucune conséquence sociale ce serait
difficilement crédible dans après plus
généralement pour aller vite ça démontre
que pour skier notamment des états unis
et notamment de notre participation à
l'otan que nous remettons en cause bon
ne faut pas avoir de naïveté les états
unis d'amérique des fentes sur beaucoup
de sujets toujours primauté de leur
propre matériel sont toujours assez
assez dur on se souvient que quand il y
avait eu c'était monsieur trump qui
étaient venus qui avait demandé à ce que
les partenaires de l'otan et 2 % de
leurs dépenses du pib qu'ils soient
consacrés aux dépenses d'un moment
c'était avec du matériel américain etc
etc donc nous devons arrêter d'être
aligné sur ces cultures notamment notre
nos stratégies de défense militaire et
sur les états unis qui ne nous font pas
de cadeaux vu que c'est eux qui ont
fortement pesé pour que les australiens
change et remettre en cause les contrats
qu'ils avaient passé avec nous parce que
c'est un déclassement de la france sur
le plan international alexis corbière
cet échec et c'est en tout cas cette
éviction de la france de ce contrat
australien moi j'aime pas les
expressions de déclassement en parler
parce qu'aujourd'hui il est ce que la
france ait sa juste place lors mais voit
l'argent de l'armement indiscutablement
façon nous avons subi du fait de la
désindustrialisation sur beaucoup de
sujets une perte d influence
après on peut s'interroger sur les
ventes d'armes et conséquences que ça
mais c'est indiscutablement des choses
qui participent à notre à notre
rayonnement même si c'est terrible de le
dire ainsi et ça montre surtout que d'un
point de vue géopolitique je pense que
nous avons perdu de la puissance et que
nous avons tort de nous aligner sur les
états unis d'amérique dans le cadre de
l'otan qu'on me comprenne bien ça ne
signifie pas que les états unis bric ne
reste pas un pays ami je n'invite pas à
ce que nous ayons une stratégie
belliqueuse vis-à-vis de ce pays serait
absurde mais du moins que du point de
vue tels que le faisait la france
pendant longtemps nous ne soyons pas
dans une dépendance du point de vue
militaire avec l'otan nous devons être
indépendants qui nous permet d'avoir
vis-à-vis de ce pays comme d'autres des
stratégies de discussions avec certains
et c'est pour qu'on me comprenne bien
qu'en dernièrement il avait été dit de
la part des états unis de monsieur
bailly donne notamment que la chine
devait être aujourd'hui était un
adversaire contre ce que disait madame
merkel et monsieur macro moi je ne pense
pas que nous devenions considéré que la
chine est un adversaire face auquel nous
devons nous nous armer je rappelle que
le budget militaire de la chine même si
on peut s'inquiéter de beaucoup de
choses ces trois fois et demie de moins
que celui des états-unis d'amérique donc
ayant des réflexions géopolitique etc
mais ne soyons pas dans une oui quand
même il n'ya pas l'armement est ce que
ça pose pas des questions sur notre
relation avec les états unis
washington est ce que ça doit s'arrêter
là où est-ce qu'il faut que ça aille
plus loin je vous ai dit moi la
conclusion que j'en tirais que jean luc
mélenchon c'est sur ton de l'otan non
mais sur la relation entre la passe je
vous ai je viens de vous décrire ce qui
est de ne peut pas faire mieux pressé de
dire à nos amis à nos amis d'amis ben
oui évidemment le peuple américain est
notre ami méritants mais combien les
choses soient claires dans cette affaire
parce qu'il ya des fois des vocabulaires
qu il rajouté moi je n'invite mais il
n'empêche que ne soyons pas naïfs ils
prendront tous les marchés et du point
de vue militaire ayant une stratégie moi
je suis pour une france indépendante qui
décide de lui c'est le parapluie
américain de défense l'otan vous assurer
la défense de l'europe comment bien
précis dans l'est de la france déjà se
doit assurer sa propre défense et vous
savez dans l'otan la turquie fait partie
de l'otan le propre de l'otan s'est
close quand c'est difficile d'ailleurs
avec les flèches entend bien que ça a
été difficile lorsqu'un des pays membres
de l'otan est agressé normalement nous
devrons être solidaires de ce pays je ne
souhaite pas être solidaire de la
stratégie de monsieur garde aux gangs
qui frappe nos amis kurdes par exemple
etc etc donc arrêtons cette hypocrisie
nous nous mettons pas dans la main des
états unis on peut parler ce qui s'est
passé en afghanistan nous intervenons au
mali et que leurs enseignements que nous
utilisons au mali situant serment en
gagnant américains semblent dépendants
et on voit bien honneur de 25% a pris
voilà et quand les etats-unis retirent
le tapis nous nous retrouvons gros jean
comme devant si je puis me permettre
alors ce qui s'est passé en afghanistan
est terrible hein on voit chez
passionnel temps parce que si on reste
sur l'international avec 6 corbières
emmanuel macron annoncé l'élimination
par les forces françaises du chef de lui
j'ai cet état islamique au grand sahara
éliminé au mali par les forces
françaises donc il ya quelques semaines
il est aussi annoncé la fin de
l'opération marquée non ce sera pas un
départ complet les forces françaises du
sel et du mali néanmoins ce que vous
craignez justement un scénario à
l'afghane et que les terroristes sont en
profite pour reprendre des positions oui
je le crains j'ai auditionné madame
paris je fais partie de la commission
défense air mais il ya quelques jours
madame par lee a fait un rapport beauté
des choses était intéressante était
quand même assez comment dirais-je
positif alors salué le courage dans la
confusion de nos troupes de nos services
diplomatiques moi je le fais mais tout
de même nous sommes retrouvés un peu
surpris si je puis dire par la situation
et on s'est retrouvé dans une situation
où je crois que faut tirer des leçons
qui nous font ça ne va pas se reproduire
et pression je prends l'exemple du mali
a vis-à-vis de madame la ministre la
défense souvenirs attention la même
situation peut se reproduire m'a dit
madame par line made in moment la
situation n'est pas comparable je lui ai
répondu si elle est comparable notamment
pas encore au point que nous avons
évoqués c'est à dire le fait que le
renseignement que nous utilisons là-bas
et celui des etats-unis et que nous ne
sommes pas totalement maître de la
situation mais pour aller à l'essentiel
sur toutes ces interventions militaires
qui ne sont pas reliés à des projets
politiques à des plantes politique cela
ne marche pas vous savez donc il
faudrait vous dites quoi le ver
expression l'époque n'aime pas les
missionnaires armés quand vous arrivez
avec des trous montaner monde pouvait
bloquer en l'occurrence était à l'époque
une intervalle une intervention
militaire qui avait empêché que la
capitale du mali ton mais assez
rapidement moi je suis allé voir les
troupes de barques anomalies et j'ai
discuté avec les officiers leur
intelligence et indiscutable nos
compétences total mais eux mêmes le
disent à l'heure actuelle nous sommes là
pour plusieurs décennies au moins 20 ans
m'avait dit le responsable l'opération
barkan c'est à dire qu'il n'ya pas le
projet politique qui va avec on a vu
quand même la situation de ce qu'ont
fait les états unis 83 milliards de
dollars qui ont été mis pour finalement
aof en toge de la corruption dit vous
restez à partir mais il faut avoir un
peu calé le plan politique comment nous
organisons et nous aidons pas nous
organisons mais nous aidons à ce que
localement si on parle de la situation
au mali il dit est un état qui se
reconstruit des services publics des
mots une vie démocratique qui se met en
place et pas le grand papa français qui
tirent les ficelles et qui
éventuellement participe à la confusion
générale parce que
on se retire mais je n'ai jamais dit on
se retire et on s'en va du jour au
lendemain parce que la situation était
on est et c'est toujours le problème
quand on intervient dans un monde sait
que la situation n'est jamais vide et on
a vu ce qui s'est passé dernièrement en
afghanistan c'est à dire du jour au
lendemain se retirer sans aucune je veux
dire programmation de politique si je
puis dire ça a des conséquences
terribles c'est toujours la politique et
quand il ya des conflits il faut
toujours discuter avec l'adversaire ça
peut sembler terrible de dire ça mais
après la question c'est comment
effectivement on ne rompt ont créé des
conditions qu'eux ils se soient les
peuples qui prennent leurs affaires en
main et pas de créer une dépendance
néocolonial souvent pour le dire
clairement un parce que ici ou là telle
ou telle énergie sur lequel on veut
continuer d'influer on va parler de la
situation sanitaire emmanuel mâcon qui
n'exclut pas la levée du passani terre
dans les départements où le virus
circule moins circle faiblement est ce
que pour vous c'est la bonne méthode oh
moi je souhaite je suis défavorable aux
à ce système de pass sanitaire je
profite de l'occasion pour aller au sila
au droit au but je suis pour que le soit
levé les suspensions des 3000 personnels
hospitaliers de santé qui sont suspendus
depuis deux jours ce que vous leur
proposez de reprendre le boulot tout
simplement nous avons besoin de cela va
amener des déprogrammations médical cela
pourquoi pas tous les matins où tous les
jours j sur mon avis sont disponibles de
ce que j'ai entendu leur proposer un
test pcr pour qu'ils puissent travailler
dans les mêmes conditions que ce qui
travaillait précédemment ces gens là ne
sont pas des délinquants ces gens là
sont des gens compétents et pour tout
dire nous en avons besoin vous avez
suivi que ça a même pour conséquence ici
ou là des fermetures de services et des
fermetures de lits qu'est ce que c'est
que cette histoire que des gens ne vont
plus touché aucun salaire parce qu'à
l'heure actuelle moi je suis favorable à
la vaccination est aussi pour cadrer un
peu le débat l'ultra majorité des
personnels de santé sont vaccinés mais
nous avons gens qui pour toute une série
de raisons on n'a toujours pas réussi à
les combes bien souvent d'ailleurs on
leur a pas proposé une visite médicale
d'aider ces gens là n'ont pas souvent
contrairement à ce qu'on croit à la
médecine du travail hélas pour des
raisons de manque de moyens n'est pas
toujours dans un rapport direct avec ces
gens là mais quoi qu'il en soit plus
têtus que disent tous les spécialistes
manière le niveau est extrêmement élevé
de vaccination chez les personnels de
santé nous avons besoin de ces
personnels nous pouvons créer les
conditions notamment je viens de le dire
par des tests pcr à ce que nous
vérifions évidemment qu'ils ne sont pas
porteurs la maladie mais je rappelle
qu'on peut être vaccinés même si la
statistique et la proportion est très
faible est aussi porteur de la maladie
donc attention à ce qu'il n'y ait pas
comme on irait jde effet d'illusion
d'optique et c'est à dire que vous
surtout ils n'ont surtout nous avons
besoin de 3000 personnes
alexis corbière que
je le dis clairement cela va trop loin
avec les organisations syndicales des
femmes et des hommes vont être suspendus
vous savez quand on a lors de la
première du premier confinement le fait
qu' il y ait eu
surcharge et c'est ça a mené 2 2 entre
deux et six mille des pro 2 et 6000
morts du fait des déprogrammations
l'intervention chirurgicale et si nous
réduisons le nombre de personnel dans
les hôpitaux nécessairement cela mène à
ce que des interventions sont
déprogrammés retardé et notamment
c'était dans le cas de cancers des
interventions qui n'ont pas eu lieu si
je répète entre deux et six mille morts
du fait du 2-2 des fermetures de
services et de la surcharge de travail
donc tout ça quand on skie bien
dotée du courant je pense notamment à ce
que dit monsieur prudhomme qui est
responsable syndical saiki médecin
urgentiste et c'est à vérifier si vous
le voulez ce que je dis ce que tout le
monde comprendra ces cas partout où il
ya une situation de surcharge de travail
ont des programmes tout le monde la vie
que vous savez moi je le vis de près
même avec les membres de ma famille
l'opl interne qui doit avoir lieu on
vous dit elle aura lieu dans d'autres
formats et xetra et tout ça des
conséquences donc il faut embaucher des
personnels certainement pas en suspens
et en plus ça crée des conditions
sociales terribles j'espère finir sur la
vaccination les sénateurs socialistes
déposent une proposition l'apprendre la
vaccination obligatoire pour tous
c'est un débat philosophique mans qui
est intéressant moi ce proc à l'heure
actuelle du point de vue il ya une telle
comment dirais-je dégradation de la
parole publique et la manière dont les
gens là croit que cinq faux récente pour
être vécu comme une mesure
supplémentaire un peu similaire à
l'obligation de ce qu'a proposé emmanuel
macron
paris j'ai peur que ça se soit maladroit
et que ça tombe à plat après l'idée moi
je suis favorable à la vaccination que
ceux qui m'écoutent je me suis fait
vacciner il faut se vacciner mais vous
savez ce que nous dit l'organisation
mondiale de la santé c'est que obliger
les gens à se vacciner ça ne produit pas
le meilleur effet efforts des politiques
publiques d'aller vers d'ailleurs
souvent ce qu'on observe c'est que la
carte de ce qui c'est maxime le moins et
la carte sociale des gens les plus
défavorisés est assez comparable je suis
un élu de seine-saint-denis je sais très
bien vous avez des gens âgés qui est
demandée immeuble sis personne va les
voir ils se marient dans la droite a
finalement vu le niveau de vaccination
qui est déjà pardonnez moi je n'aime pas
mais je veux pas esquivé je ne connais
pas ce texte donc je vais en rester là
mais je vous avais compris mon état
d'esprit intellectuellement des
campagnes de vaccination oui à l'heure
actuelle ce serait à mon avis faire bis
repetita de ce café macron mêmes causes
mêmes effets on va parler des questions
sociales justement le gouvernement qui a
annoncé ces dernières heures une
rallonge du chèque énergie et à la fin
de l'année qui a annoncé des hausses de
salaires pour les sages femmes qui
travaillent dans les hôpitaux sont rhône
est de prime 100 euros de brut de
hausses de salaires finalement c'est
président de pouvoir d'achat quand vient
la période électorale d'un seul coup
beaucoup de choses se font qui semblait
difficile on avait déposé un amendement
qui demandait exactement sur le chèque
énergie la rallonge ça nous avait été
refusé députés dans marche avait voté
qu'on
est totalement totalement c'est le
problème de la
meilleure la condition des gens je m'en
félicite maintenant je dis gare aux
effets d'optique nous on propose une loi
d'urgence sociale vous avez peut-être
entendu jean leclant champs ce sujet vu
qu'à une loi d'urgence c'est sur la
question de sécurité qui a une loi
d'urgence nous dit-on sur nombre de
sujets pourquoi pas une loi d'urgence
sociale parce que la crise allait
sociale on a quand même ça c'est un
bilan d' emmanuel macron on est passé de
9 millions de gens qui vivaient sous le
seuil de pauvreté en 2017 lors de son
arrivée aujourd'hui sans doute à moins
11 millions de gens qui vivent sous le
seuil de pauvreté
indiscutablement ça a été parce que
j'allais terminer mon raisonnement en
même temps sur les gens les 350 divona
350 milliardaire en france on et
recommande d'europe ils ont vu leur
fortune quasiment doux et où augmenté de
400 30% donc quand vous avez un telle
delta qui se créent augmentation de la
pauvreté avec des situations qu'on a vue
qui est assez difficile on pourrait
rentrer dans les détails moi j'ai été
choqué vous allez dire que c'est
anecdotique quand on en vient au point
que dans certaines même commune un
enfant parce que les parents n'ont pas
payé la cantine on envoie la police
municipale peut le ramener à la maison
qu'on a des chiffres incroyables qui
montrent que 30 % de nos retraités sont
en situation
sous le seuil de pauvreté qu'on a un
demi million de retraités qui doivent
aller travailler pour pouvoir on peut
finir les fins de mois et qu'à l'inversé
vous avez des profits qui éclatent des
inégalités qui se creusent
indiscutablement c'est la faute du
président de la république vu qu'il est
aujourd'hui on le sait bien celui qui
concentre tous les pouvoirs donc là
alexis corbière c'est un président en
campagne que vous voyez oui
un président obama clairement en
campagne avec des moyens publics je veux
dire ce qu'ils apparentent déclaré ça me
vient en tête à marseille l'autre jour
vous savez n'aura d'efficacité que s'il
était réélu donc on aurait quand même
s'interroger de comment ça se fait que
quand jean-luc mélenchon est en campagne
désormais chacune de dépenses publiques
et c'est bien normal on fait bien la
distinction entre ce que l'activité d'un
parlementaire et ce qui est l'activité
donne candidat mais quand c'est le
président de la république qui peut tout
raconter dire que si on vote pour lui
voilà ce qu'il fera sans que nul ne
s'interroge tout de même est ce que
c'est au contribuable de financer la
campagne de emmanuel public doit pas
s'arrêter ton pardon à l'inversé les
jeunes parlent pas de l'action publique
ne s'est pas l'action publique est une
chose la promesse pour un fionn un
deuxième mandat cet autre chose en
conviendrez évident je ne demande pas si
emmanuel macron quitte le bureau de
l'elysée et cessent toute activité je
dis seulement qu'il ya une chose qui est
les affaires jusqu'à la peur de la été
élu et il ya après le programme est
qu'il propose et ça vous a pas échappé
je prends l'exemple de marseille que
beaucoup de choses qui me proposait son
s'il est réélu donc on aurait quand même
à ce moment là dire attention monsieur
le président la vous n'êtes plus
présidente d'être le candidat
d'ailleurs d'être le candidat à un
deuxième mandat on a bien compris qu
emmanuel macron sera candidat et
pourquoi pas si en a qui aiment qu'ils
en utilisant reprennent mais il ya aussi
beaucoup de gens qui aimeraient ce que
les règles soient peu près identique et
ça c'est des choses importantes parle de
financement de campagne marine le pen à
écrire macron pour l'alerter sur les
difficultés de financement de la
campagne présidentielle elle demande au
parlement d'offrir de nouvelles
possibilités de financement vous
soutenez cette démarche je ne sais pas
ce qu'elle est il beaucoup de l'équipe
autour d' emmanuel macron c'était
monsieur berrou aussi qui est proposée
une banque que j'ai oublié le nom public
effectivement pour financer les
campagnes c'est un vrai sujet c'est un
vrai sujet
oui je ne vous réunissait pas comme ça
de l'argent ou saïda la 1ère fois jean
luc mélenchon avait hypothéqué son
propre appartement etc bon donc c'est
des choses qui sont pas évidentes moi
même comme candidat je me suis un
élection législative j'avais eu du mal à
trouver une banque qui me prêtait de
l'argent pour pouvoir avoir mon budget
qu'on ait des élections légistatives et
si je suis sans doute candidat la
prochaine fois je ne croyais pas que
c'est simple qu'une banque vous avance
l'argent tout ça est assez compliqué
donc ça fait partie des choses qu'il
faut remettre en cause mais c'est qu'est
ce que je vous dise une des inégalités
de la période mais je voulais revenir je
passe mon sujet qu'on va aborder sur le
fait qu' il faut changer ce système aux
six ans pour laquelle nous on n'est pas
en finir avec cette cinquième république
autant de pouvoir concentrer sur le
président de la république on est pour
passer à une sixième république on est
pour que les citoyens ils devront à
nouveau c'est le droit sera dans les
campagnes alexis caude annoncera encore
dans la campagne de jean luc mélenchon
c'est déjà le cas
vous savez ce qu'on a fait en 2012 qui a
progressé en 2010 est doit continuer
cette fois ci on a fait 11 % la dernière
fois dix neuf et demi pour ça on peut
faire plus et au vu de ce que disent les
études d'opinion vous allez dire que je
commence à regarder utiliser son âge si
on refaisait la même chose que dans la
foi jean luc mélenchon peut être au
deuxième tour donc j'invite tout le
monde à se regrouper derrière ce qu'on
essaie de faire c'est difficile bien
entendu pour l'instant le regroupement
et magna gauche salaires d'être c'est
parti on a le temps encore mais il y a
des gens ou savait qu'il cessait de dire
qu' il y fallait l'union si nos âmes
perdues d'avancé je pense à à nos amis
je veux le montre guillemets mais je des
bonnes relations humaines avec eux du ps
est élevé il était soi-disant
obligatoire n'ont semblent ils ont réuni
des gens pour dire que ça y est c'est
fait ils ne le sont pas moi je pense
plutôt à nos amis communistes par
exemple on a fait ces campagnes que j'ai
évoqué cela ensemble et c'était
formidable et ça a permis à nos amis
communistes aussi d'avoir des députés
ç'a permis aux amis comme univers aux
régionales ils sont partis et clic les
socialistes les régionales ont leur
propre grammaire
la municipale aussi avec eux parce qu'on
a bien bossé elle est déterminée
jusqu'au il le faut t il il fera ce
qu'ils souhaitent moi je ne suis pas non
plus chaud depuis encore des discute je
suis dans le respect de chacun dans son
je répète ce que nous avons dit ce que
j'en ai pour longchamp a dit discutons
discutons pourquoi pas mais vous dites
accord législatif et bien je propose
qu'on leur fasse mais
ça ne s'est pas formalisé et faisons le
à l'heure actuelle mais comme en irak là
aussi c'est toujours difficile parce que
j'écoutais votre reportage avant les
communistes sont une grande force ils
ont organisé la fête de l'humanité ils
ont beaucoup d'élus tout à fait
respectable ils ont le savoir faire
indiscutable au jeu je ne les toits ce
pas je ne suis pas en train d'avoir une
mauvaise passe en train de leur dire
qu'ils sont crédités de 2% à regarder
les sondages car il est dynamique de
campagne beaucoup de choses pour lui je
suis en valeur des légendes alexis
corvée je suis en train de leur dire
qu'ensemble en fond bleu et nous ce que
nous avons fait la dernière fois 2017 et
2012 est plus qu un bon résultat c'était
historique d'accor dix neuf et demi le
parti communiste et la france insoumise
c'est historique sur un candidat commun
qui s'appelait jean luc mélenchon à ce
stade je le confesse je n'ai pas compris
pourquoi dragons ce que nous avions fait
ensemble à des enfants serait impossible
cette fois ci d'autant que cette fois ci
alors on nous parlons cela permettrait
de créer des conditions que nous soyons
au second tour et pourquoi pas même de
l'emporter voilà ce que vous n'êtes pas
parti trop tôt est ce que vous avez pas
une part de responsabilité jean luc
mélenchon il est parti très tôt en
campagne sur son nom des parties sans
contribuer l'éparpillement à la date
auquel jean luc mélenchon aussi sa
candidature c'est à dire en février
dernier était exactement la même date
que ce qu'il avait annoncé en 2007 mais
il est le premier candidat de gauche à
cette lancée il fallait je
ne crois pas pour quelle raison au
contraire ça a participé à ce
regroupement l'éparpillement c'est pas
notre faute toute une série de gens ont
dit et quand vous dites moi je serai
candidat j'irai jusqu'au bout quoi qu'il
arrive en quoi ça participe au
rassemblement parce que vous avez nombre
de gens voient bien qu'ils mènent un jeu
totalement je vais le dire hypocrite de
la part de certains disant s'il faut se
regrouper si on se regroupe en a perdu
d'avancé pour les nationalistes et
cialis veulent absolument à voir leurs
candidats ils sont galvanisés par leur
état des régionales et ils disent
aujourd'hui olivier faur l'a dit je
respecte sa parole nous sommes la force
majoritaire c'est derrière nous je vois
très bien que les écologistes parce que
nous on a été extrêmement disponible à
l'occasion des régionales on a proposé à
corps les écologistes et à derrière nous
ou rien bon après vous discuté avec des
gens je pense arnaud montebourg qui dit
moi je vais y aller un bon tout le monde
vous dit qu'il veuille alexis corbière
imagine pas une seconde que jean luc
mélenchon se rallient derrière un autre
candidat de gauche d'ailleurs on
pourrait parler programme nous et qu
est-ce que c qui est la singularité de
ce que nous faisons nous avons un
programme beaucoup de gens sont
candidats et candidates notamment sans
programme et moi je dis à nos
concitoyens un candidat sans programme
il est dangereux pour la démocratie là
je parle notamment d'anne hidalgo
franchement je ne sais une candidate à
l'heure actuelle oui alors actuelle oui
elle même elle l'a dit d'ailleurs j'ai
peut-être à la fin de l'année alors je
dis à madame hidalgo cantonné
républicain puis j'ai envie de dire même
vulgairement ou de gauche fois on
commence d'abord par le programme et les
propositions et on voit petit lot porte
jean luc mélenchon s'il est candidat
c'est parce qu'il dit nous avons
notamment de mener les deux campagnes
j'ai dit à l'heure j'ai un programme qui
va être réactualisé et je pense que je
suis le mieux disposé à faire le mieux
qu'on est placée pour porter ce
programme c'est pas la même démarche que
quelqu'un qui vous dit j'ai bien
réfléchi je suis si on reviendra si on
reste sur un hidalgo vous paraître
propositions il y en a une qui est sorti
le doublement du salaire des enseignants
c'est une mesure de gauche par l'amp ça
vous vous le résumer comme ça j'ai
écouté certains de ces deux jours je
pose la question mais déjà cette
proposition je ne sais pas si c'est
celle d'anne hidalgo parce que sarkozy
la formule certains de ses proches ont
dit je pense autant chez casto sein de
ce programme que ça ne concerne que les
jeunes enseignants qui rentre dans le
métier de déjà entre ce qu'elle dit elle
dont elle dit que c'est elle va voir
c'est un objectif qu'il faudrait essayer
donc qui sera décidée fin décembre est
ce que dit ensuite son responsable du
projet c'est plus la même proposition je
vous taquine mais c'est révélateur c'est
à dire que ce qui est positif je vais
donner le point à cette discussion c'est
bien qu'on parle des salaires tant mieux
il vaut mieux parler de ça que de savoir
si on est en droit de s'appeler mohamed
en france franchement ca c'est dégradant
d'avoir cette discussion qui est
vraiment dégradantes intellectuellement
par rapport à ce que méritent notre beau
pays et nos concitoyens dont je veux
discuter des enseignants nous on propose
depuis un moment et que jean luc
lachance était au coeur notre programme
de revaloriser le salaire des
enseignants sur la base au moins deux
trapé les conséquences du gel du point
d'indicé que les socialistes et les amis
d'hervé didier lebon ont mis en place on
me dit si à de la surenchère pourquoi
pas mais restons d'abord mon sèche un
peu un peu bébête à ce que propose
l'unanimité des organisations syndicales
d'enseignants rattraper cela ça peut
entraîner une hausse du pouvoir d'achat
et des salaires des anciens de 30% ça
vaut le coup c'est celle probable de
mélenchon c'était solide 2017 contre
lequel les socialistes s'étaient élevées
mais si on dispute salaire tant mieux
mais ça passe par un partage dernière
alexis corbière le temps fiez vous en
êtes où de la course aux parrainages on
y travaille justement tout ça vous
rendez vous évoquez l'argent ça prend du
temps ça veut dire vous n'avez pas vos
500 parrainages en année plus de la
moitié mais ont mis en avant c'est un
homme interné on n'a jamais dit que
c'était simple et je lance un appel vu
que je sais que public sénat et sans
doute regardé par beaucoup de maires non
seulement on y travaille le programme
des gens du clan sion mais j'ai envie de
dire m sur le terrain de la démocratie
même si vous ne partagez pas ce que je
dit estimer quand même que ce que nous
représentons et en courant qui existe
dans ce pays et il serait terrible il
serait terrible que nous ne puissions
pas pour des raisons comme ça de cette
institutionnalisation gamme république
ira boukris sur le sujet que nous
puissions pas nous présenter donc on y
travaille ça prend du temps ça ne mange
pas dans l'expression beaucoup des nerfs
mais on va y arriver de toute manière
j'ai passé merci avec ces corps du rc
faire ça nous regarde ensemble à une
deux choses il y en a ce matin au comité
à bordeaux eu envie que chamboule tous
étaient là et n'a de sud ouest ont l'air
hier le maire écologiste de bord
exactement merci préfère ça merci je
vais avoir été avec ce merci alexis
corbière
[Musique]